[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
recently we did that iphone 10 revisited
video six months later and that was a
lot of fun but as a lot of you guys
pointed out in the comments the only
phone to spend more time in my pocket
over the last couple months than that
iphone
was this guy the pixel 2 xl and it's
true a lot of people ask over the course
of the last eight months that this phone
has been out what phone do you choose or
use the most often and a lot of times i
come back to this one so we can look
back at the time since this phone has
come out and see how well it's aged
what's happened to it since then whether
it's been graceful or not and this is
our look at that now a lot's happened to
the pixel actually it's gotten a number
of software updates android p beta has
come out recently i started using that
because why not and we just had google i
o and a bunch more software and ai
features announced that are coming to
pixel first so for one the promise of
being first in line for new google and
android stuff when it comes out if you
have a pixel that definitely lives on no
doubt but the hardware story of this
thing is actually just as interesting in
a lot of ways so this is the white one
the panda pixel 2 as i call it and i
love the white i've carried it every day
with no case no skin naked and you can
see there's definitely a little bit of
chipping a little bit of scratching and
the overall texture of the whole back is
a lot smoother now that it's worn down
but i can say for sure it's held up well
it actually hasn't stained in white and
it is still mostly metal after all so
i've dropped it from low heights i've
had it hit things in my pocket
accidentally no serious damage it's been
super solid i i do wish this phone had
wireless charging though it's one of
those weird few flagships left that
doesn't have a glass back but at the
same time i realize that this type of
durability and the mostly metal body
don't allow for wireless charging so
that's a trade-off that you get and
turns out i'm fine with it but a
moonshot goal of mine with technology is
actually even with a phone with this
little bit of glass on the back whether
it's for looks or for cell reception or
whatever to have wireless charging just
up in here and to put it on a mat
somewhere and just have it work
would be pretty sweet i i don't
necessarily need the whole back of the
phone to be glass
for wireless charging but that's
probably pretty far off uh the not
having a headphone jack same as the
iphone 10 you do get used to that after
having this phone for eight months you
know i've gotten wireless headphones it
connects via bluetooth as soon as i get
into my car and just overall even though
it isn't the prettiest phone with the
thinnest bezels on the glass everywhere
the stormtrooper look the colored power
button the front-facing speakers i like
all of it it's all a trade-off in
certain ways but i'm a fan of the way
this hardware has held up and then of
course there is one of the most unique
parts of this phone's hardware which is
the pressure sensitive sides the squeeze
feature
not a lot of phones have done the
squeeze at all since then
but it's been alright i'd say my biggest
complaint is it's starting to feel kind
of slow like double tapping the camera
for example the physical button that
stayed pretty quick now i use google
assistant all the time but squeezing the
size of the phone when it's off to
activate the assistant you wait a beat
and then it's fired up and you start
talking otherwise you'll get cut off
it's mildly annoying but not enough to
get me to stop using it i just wait that
beat and it's worth it because google
assistant has been getting so good i
mean did you see all the improvements
google just added to the assistant just
in the past week at i o there's a lot of
good stuff they added all those
predictive behaviors and routines they
added a full screen ui they added six
new voices with also plans to add
literally john legend's voice as a voice
for the assistant i don't know why john
legend i mean he's cool and everything
but what about like david attenborough
or morgan freeman or something i don't
know but they also improved continuous
conversations so you don't have to say
okay google over and over again you can
just keep talking to it and it'll keep
answering questions and it'll follow up
with context-related answers and even
what we talked about in the last video
where it will eventually make phone
calls for you so yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna keep squeezing and keep using the
assistant and then with the software and
everything apps that are built for
android will for sure work on pixel
obviously this is the premier android
experience as much features as other
skins and manufacturers tend to add to
android if you just want support if you
want the least amount of bugginess if
you want the fastest updates
that's still pixel and there's a bunch
of other smaller observations like the
fingerprint reader on the back of this
phone is still a plus position and speed
for me i don't think i would make a
single change to that
battery life has held up great even
through the beginning of my testing with
the android p beta and the fact that
it's one of the last phones with stereo
front-facing speakers is severely
underrated we're all moving to these
bezel-less phones right and we all
wonder what do you do with the
front-facing camera what do you do with
those sensors but ultimately when you
get rid of the space around these
screens speakers will absolutely suffer
with that and the days of boom sounds
massive stereo speakers
uh are pretty much over with modern
smartphone design maybe razer phone 2
will be the last dinosaur but for now
i'm enjoying it and then the camera the
single single camera on the back of this
phone this is still the best camera in
any smartphone period i can still say
that the many months later now that it's
out it doesn't have the highest dxo mark
score of any smartphone anymore but it
is still my preferred camera and i think
i'll probably end up doing some sort of
an updated blind test of the best
smartphone cameras maybe leave a thumbs
up if you're into that but for now this
is in my pocket a big part of it is
because of the camera a lot of the
photos i've shared over the past couple
months on twitter and instagram have
come from this camera believe it or not
uh i didn't always do that i often used
like a sony a7r or whatever handheld
camera i wanted to take photos to share
but this is definitely in the category
of one of those cameras that just
encourages you to take photos and often
they're pretty great you end up having
more to share the main reason a lot of
phones have added that second lens over
the years is portrait mode and optical
zoom
but pixel 2 still has excellent portrait
mode in fact better than most with all
the software optimizations despite not
having a second camera and that's thanks
to the pixel shift i talked about in the
full review it's really great and then i
will say with with zooming in and out
you obviously you will get more crisp
photos with a telephoto camera with
optical zoom but i tend to not use that
as much like even when i have a 2x
button in the camera i've stopped using
that a lot on iphone on galaxy note and
galaxy s i'm more of like a zoom with my
feet kind of guy so it's not as big of a
deal for me to not have a telephoto
camera but anyway really my biggest
annoyance with this whole phone
and it has been since day one it was a
point of contention in all the reviews
and people talking about it when this
phone came out
and that's the screen there's a lot of
drama around it and you can see why it's
pretty bright it's not the brightest and
it's not the most color accurate and it
had a little bit of a blue cast to it
depending on when you got your panel
basically i've had to calibrate to it
like when a phone has a certain notable
quality to it like this you have to
remember that and that's not ideal after
all the complaints about the color space
google added those different color modes
so natural then boosted and saturated
i've used it in boosted mode which is
like 10 maybe boosted saturation versus
the original because the saturated is
way too dramatic unfortunately and like
i shoot tons of photos for twitter and
instagram and stuff like that to share
on this camera and then i edit them on
this screen and tweak them in google
photos and i have to remember to
calibrate for the colors i'm looking at
on this screen versus how it will look
on everyone else's screens that's really
the biggest difference of what it comes
down to and you have to remember that
when you get a phone with a particularly
different piece of hardware like this uh
but it's not ideal at all so all that
being said you know we know we know
about pixel 2
what are we thinking about pixel 3 we've
talked about it a little bit in past
videos but
what would i expect out of the next
pixel first of all the camera is the
most important piece of this phone and i
hope they can do it better next year i
don't necessarily know how google would
do that i have a feeling they're going
to stick to one lens but i just i hope
they can actually build on what's
already an incredible camera and i'd
love for it to have an awesome screen
for them to use a quality oled panel
maybe a samsung panel whatever it takes
and then to just catch up a bit in
modern design the last pixel the last
nexus and this one haven't really been
on the forefront of smartphone design so
when i say those two things it probably
means you'll end up having a notch
that's just where we're at in 2018 i get
it but those are the two biggest
drawbacks i think of this phone when it
comes to regular people is the screens
had some complaints and the design is
not so hot step those two things up and
pixel 3 will probably be
pretty high on my list so at the end of
the day now that we're revisiting this
phone
it's it's held up really well the price
hasn't really dropped at all which is
kind of weird usually it does by this
point but if you're thinking about
buying this phone i can still say also
that it's worth it uh the only reason
not to buy it would be the fact that a
bunch of phones are about to come out
oneplus 6 is about to come out lg g7 is
about to come out and even if you still
want to be on that stock android train
and be first in line for updates and get
android p and everything
october is not that far away i mean i
guess it's after summer but that's about
when we're expecting the next one so if
you can hold off that long pixel 3 maybe
then this price will drop but for now
this is a really great phone i'm happy
with it
thanks for watching
talk to you the next one
peace